hi mystery recap here today i am going
to explain an american drama television
film called to be fat like me
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
alison is an overweight high school
senior she is kind and polite to
everyone but doesn't quite get the same
treatment from others because of her
looks one morning she gets on the bus to
go to school her simple existence makes
people roll their eyes even though she
apologizes for nothing at school she
goes to her first class and compliments
a guy's shirt in turn he looks at her
weirdly and doesn't seem grateful
another man calls her a cow and everyone
else laughs in fact the only person who
smiles at her is another overweight girl
at the end of the classroom during lunch
she politely approaches the popular
girls asking if she can sit with them
but they reply to her kindness with
insults similarly she is catcalled and
looked down upon everywhere she goes by
the end of the lunch break she is almost
in tears she rushes to the school's
bathroom and takes off her clothes
revealing that she is actually wearing a
fat suit that makes her look overweight
when in reality she has the ideal body
type that most people desire it is
alison's first day as an overweight girl
the scene shifts to a few months earlier
alison has always been popular and has
never had any difficulty making friends
she is in her last year of high school
and is excited about college the only
problem is that she hasn't been able to
collect enough money for her college
fees yet it turns out that her college
funds were used as medical bills for her
mother who got sick because of binge
eating ever since then allison dislikes
people who do not take care of their
bodies and eat whatever they please she
also frequently taunts her family for
having a cake or a pizza once in a while
her little brother adam is fat and is
always bullied in school but alison
thinks it is because of his unlikable
personality although she never means
harm to her family alison is unaware of
the privileges she gets for being pretty
currently she is working hard to earn a
softball scholarship for college she is
very close to getting one but when she
is informed a group of scouts from the
university is coming to test her the
next day alison is overjoyed and hopes
to do her best that day on her way back
home she saves her brother from a bunch
of bullies he isn't thankful because she
made him look like a coward who hides
behind his elder sister at home alison
refuses to take a bite of the cake that
her mother has made for her the family
hates it when she makes them feel bad
for eating but does not complain then at
work she is approached by a popular guy
from school named michael he asks her
out on a date and the two go on a walk
michael is also an athlete so the two
have a lot in common he promises to come
to her game the next day which makes
alison more nervous in the following
scene alison and her team are playing
softball in front of the scouts she does
well in the game until an opponent
accidentally jumps on her leg and
injures her knee as a result not only
does she not get the scholarship but has
to quit playing sports altogether after
months of physical therapy she gets back
to walking but her chances of getting
into college are far gone by now she is
sitting outside her house one day
thinking of what could be done next when
adam returns home with both his shoes
missing alison advises him to be less
sarcastic so the bullies will be nicer
to him but the comment couldn't be
further from the truth adam tells her
that people dislike him before he even
opens his mouth because of how he looks
when alison refuses to believe him he
reminds her that she has no say in the
topic since she has always had
privileges because she is pretty later
her mother tries to cheer her up but
alison blames her for all the problems
she is facing this causes a rift in
their relationship but she couldn't care
less the next day at school allison's
friend sarah comes to her with a flyer
about a state level competition one
should make a documentary about the
challenges high schoolers face in their
day-to-day life and the winning prize is
ten thousand dollars sarah allows alison
to take all the money if they were to
win since she only wants exposure
because there is no other way for alison
to earn enough money for college she
takes the deal she is sure that her
younger brother and mother use their
struggles with weight as an excuse for
everything wrong in their lives and is
convinced that even if she was fat
people would be nice to her because of
her personality hence she decides to be
fat for a month to test the theory they
can call the documentary to be fat like
me inspired by john howard griffin's
1961 book black like me in the following
scene sarah gives alison a complete
makeover making her turn from size zero
to overweight they also place a hidden
camera in her backpack and glasses so
they can film how people treat her on
her first day at a new school as a fat
girl alison is confident that if she is
nice to people they will be nice to her
sarah suggests she try to talk to as
many people as she can especially the
popular girls but only a few hours in
allison realizes how wrong she was about
the topic the only people who are nice
to her are a fellow overweight girl
ramona and her friend george they even
invite her to join their study group
after the mental breakdown in the
bathroom she brings out the camera in
her bag and yells that she hates her fat
body this makes her realize what other
people who are not as conventionally
attractive have to go through on a
regular basis and this is only after a
few hours alison is a wiener outside she
meets her teacher from her former school
who catches her in the act he doesn't
necessarily support her but asks to see
the final result of the documentary to
judge if she is doing the right thing
later that day alison and michael hang
out with their friends on the basketball
court the guys jokingly say that a way
to know that girls won't gain weight in
10 years is by looking at their mothers
they also make fun of fat people and say
that they would never date them michael
agrees to everything which makes alison
feel a bit strange still she dismisses
the topic and kisses him the two started
dating when she got back from therapy
and have been together ever since the
following day alison goes on a study
date with ramona and george she has
decided to film them to get more insight
into how people like them are treated
however allison fails to comprehend that
she is violating their privacy by
recording them when they are vulnerable
in front of her when she and ramona are
alone alison finds out she is in love
with george but ramona denies it after
that the girls go shopping but are told
to go to another store because their
size is not available ramona is used to
being treated like that but alison is
furious at the rude sales girl she
creates a scene and makes her apologize
ramona is shocked as to how she is so
confident because the bullies and
constant taunts have made her a coward
long ago the comments make alison
realize why people don't usually stand
up for themselves and that makes her
feel awful she decides to use this clip
of ramona in the documentary in the
following scene allison and george are
outside a restaurant talking george
seems to be interested in her but alison
thinks he's just being friendly suddenly
she notices michael and her best friend
jamie hugging each other and driving off
she tells george she is dating michael
which surprises him since guys like
michael do not go for overweight girls
that evening alison sees her brother
hesitating to talk to a girl he likes
because he is not confident about his
looks she makes him understand that if
he lets the bully's comments get to him
they will win adam is happy that his
sister is giving him good advice for
once at the end of the day sarah gathers
up the footage from the videos of ramona
she makes fat phobic jokes and expects
alison to agree because she is thin
herself she also insists on putting
ramona's video in the documentary
because it is good content however
alison doesn't want to include her in
the project anymore because they will be
broadcasting her entire life to the
people it's mean and it's also flat out
illegal the next day alison and her
group score a b-plus on their project
and go out to celebrate as they are
bowling a group of teenage boys starts
bullying ramona when alison stands up
against them they pour water on her head
this causes her prosthetics to rip off
and the truth is revealed in front of
ramona and george allison tries telling
them that it is for a documentary but it
only makes them feel worse for the next
few days alison leaves ramona several
messages apologizing and asking for a
chance to explain herself but ramona
refuses to reply michael also notices
the shift in alison's attitude and asks
her what is wrong she doesn't tell him
about the documentary and dismisses it
by claiming she is stressed about the
upcoming test one day on returning home
alison finds george sitting outside he
has come to give her study material so
she could do better on the test since
she has been skipping classes to refrain
from wearing the fat suit starting the
next day alison studies harder than she
ever has she had never thought of
getting good grades for scholarships
because it was never her thing but after
a little motivation from george she
begins believing in herself on the day
of the test she gets into the fat suit
for the last time and goes to school
ramona completes hers the fastest and
walks outside alison runs behind her
begging for a chance to explain herself
however ramona tells her how horrible of
a person she is for filming her at her
most vulnerable moment because she has
never been that open with anyone before
she drives away right after leaving
allison feeling guilty after that
allison shows the finished documentary
to her professor who claims that it ends
abruptly they still have to find a way
to conclude it at home alison's mother
finds out about the fat suit and her
project she thinks alison is trying to
mock her by wearing the costume they get
into a huge fight alison calls her
selfish for getting fat and reveals that
she hated having a bigger mom growing up
alison has learned nothing she regrets
saying that right after but her mother
locks herself into a room before she can
apologize alison goes to sarah with an
idea to conclude the project she wants
to go to a party dressed up as her fat
self and see how people she already
knows treat her in the end she will
reveal her true self and make a
statement they put their plan into
action even though alison is very
nervous she finds rini flirting with
michael at the party and feels worse
than she already does she is pushed
around and laughed at by everyone in the
end she takes off the prosthetic on her
face and belittles the guys who bullied
her and the ones who laughed sarah gets
her footage and she teaches everyone how
mean they are to people for no reason
michael is hurt because alison didn't
tell him about the project and kept
lying to him instead in the following
scene alison returns home and is
confronted by her father about what she
said to her mother earlier alison
apologizes and claims that she said
those words out of frustration but she
didn't mean them the next morning she
apologizes to her mother as well and the
two make amends they agree to talk to
each other about their feelings more
often that day ramona also comes to
visit allison after her anger calms down
she thinks that the documentary will do
her good since she will finally be able
to show people how they have been to her
she allows alison to keep the clips on
it then we see michael and alison
together he accepts her for who she is
and forgives her for lying he has
watched the documentary and knows that
what she did was for good the movie ends
as the last clip from the documentary is
shown alison narrates that being fat is
more about your weight it is about
knowing that you are the one who owns
your body hence the judgments that other
people pass are as irrelevant as it gets
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching